being a good listener is one of the most
important and enchanting life skills
anyone can have yet few of us know how
to do it not because we're evil but
because no one has taught us how and a
related point no one has listened to us
so we come to social life greedy to
speak rather than listen hungry to meet
others but reluctant to hear them
friendship degenerates into a socialized
egoism like most things it's about
education our civilization is full of
great books on how to speak Cicero's
orator and Aristotle's rhetoric would
serve the greatest in the ancient world
but sadly no one has ever written a book
called the listener there are a range of
things that the good listener is doing
that makes it so nice to spend time in
their company firstly they egg us on
it's hard to know our own minds often
we're in the vicinity of something but
we don't quite close in on what's really
bothering or exciting us we hugely
benefit from encouragement to elaborate
to go into greater detail to push just a
little further we need someone who
rather than launch forth on their own
will simply say those two magic words
go on you mention a sibling and they
want to know a bit more what was the
relationship like in childhood how's it
changed over time they're curious where
our concerns and excitements come from
they ask things like why did that
particularly bother you why was that
such a big thing for you they keep our
histories in mind they might refer back
to something we said before and we feel
they're building up a deeper vase of
engagement secondly the good listener
urges clarification it's fatally easy to
say vague things we simply mentioned
that something is lovely or terrible
nice or annoying but we don't really
explore why we feel this way the friend
who listens often has a productive
friendly suspicion of some of our own
first statements and is after the deeper
attitudes that are lurking in the
background they take things we say like
I'm fed up with my job or my partner and
I having a lot of rouse and they help us
to focus
in on what it really is about the job we
don't like or what the Rao's are really
about they're bringing to listening an
ambition to clarify the underlying
issues they don't just see conversation
as the swapping of anecdotes they're
reconnecting the chat you're having over
pizza with the philosophical ambitions
of Socrates whose dialogues are records
of his attempts to help fellow Athenians
understand their ideas and values in a
better way
thirdly good listeners don't moralize
the good listener is acutely aware of
how insane we all are they know their
own minds well enough not to be
surprised or frightened about this
they're skilled at making occasional
little positive sounds strategic mmm
that delicately signals sympathy without
intruding on what we're trying to say
they give the impression that they
recognize and accept our follies they're
reassuring us they're not going to shred
our dignity a big worry in a competitive
world is that we feel we can't afford to
be honest about how distressed we are
saying one feels like a failure could
mean being dropped but the good listener
signals early and clearly that they
don't see us in these terms our
vulnerability is something they warm to
rather than are appalled by lastly good
listeners separate disagreement from
criticism there's a huge tendency to
feel that being disagreed with is an
expression of hostility and obviously
sometimes that's right but a good
listener makes it clear that they can
really like you and at the same time
think you're wrong they make it plain
that their liking for you isn't
dependent on constant agreement they're
powerfully aware that a really lovely
person could end up a bit muddled and in
need of some gentle untangling when
we're in the company of people who
listen well we experience a very
powerful pleasure but too often we don't
really realize what it is that this
person's doing that's so nice by paying
strategic attention to the pleasure we
can learn to magnify it and offer it to
others who will notice here and repay
the favor in turn listening deserves
every as one of the keys to a good
society
through life thinking that there's a
right way to do things in a wrong way to
do things and there isn't a whole lot of
room for subjectivity
from my perspective andrey troubles
around communicating our intentions and
emotions clearly and honestly this is
some of what we get up to as an
alternative to straightforward
communication